at number 18 our next grandmaster is
doing more than reading the tea leaves
Mateus Lehmann filmed this South Asian
tea pool or at work I didn't realize
that I was making tea the wrong way I
mean I pretty much was stuck to a 2d
plane a natural fact you need to make
tea in three dimensions but how's he
managing to move the tea from cup to cup
without spilling a drop
as he's spinning the tea has inertia
which means it wants to stay in its
original place
but he's forcing it around with a cup
the result of this is that it
experienced a centrifugal effect which
pushes the tea to the bottom of the cup
at the same time gravity is pulling the
tea out of the cup so there's a
competition between gravity and the
centrifugal effect yeah but with two
forces acting on the tea how does he
know which one's gonna win as he spins
it faster the tea is gonna stay stuck in
the mug and he basically counteract
gravity now he doesn't want the tea to
stay stuck in one mug the whole time he
wants it to flow down to the other mug
so he can slow down and spin a little
bit allow it to flow down but still keep
spinning to keep a little bit of control
over the whole thing
so next time you're asked how you like
your tea ask for extra physics